so there's a guy I'm not going to tell
you what kind of guy he is that I met at
the gym this morning and he just found
out that he realized that uh I live in
uh Nevada but I come here quite a bit
and he goes oh you're a by Wester a by
West so what kind of guy was this I
don't know is he a tax guy he sounds
like a yeah
[Music]
okay did you guys hear about the alien
in Miami no I heard about it but I
didn't see it but I also heard there's a
video there is a video Miami alien yes
it's a good spot to would you guys like
to well first of all let me describe the
incident for you so in Miami at a at a
mall um there was an incident and they
they every single cop in Miami showed up
to respond to it okay oh was that why
there was like 50,000 cop cars outside
yes and [__] so all immediately on
social media the was was first of all
the cops were saying there was an
incident involving a fight with school
kids or whatever like the young
teenagers okay and then people who are
who were in the Miami who were at the
mall they're like that's not what
happened there's a [__] alien walking
around and people like what and they're
like yeah there's like Shadow aliens
walking around what the [__] what the
hell what's a shadow alien part of me
wants this to be real alien that like a
shadow damn please be real and
everyone's freaking out everyone's
freaking the out so you guys want see
the video yeah oh my God yes I didn't
know they had video you see the shadow
alien yeah let me let me give give me
one second to make sure that I'm showing
you the correct the exact R Video on did
anybody see it yet no but I have friends
that have seen it and then I even
scrolled past it but then once I
scrolled past it I wanted to go back I
was just too lazy I just kept going this
way must have been captivating Bart must
have been a sick video I just saw when
it happened when there were a lot of cop
cars and people were like what's going
on what's really going going on and then
I didn't know what happened after all
right no spoilers no spoilers no
spoilers don't say
anything is there volume to this or not
no wait what is that there just cop cars
that looks like something is walking
sideways on like what is that that's
somebody this looks like footage from
dipping quick why is this footage from
the I don't know what the [__] that is
it's it's like a big alien walking
around it's like a red circle why don't
they catch it why don't they catch it
yeah why not they catching say you're
under arrest freeze I don't even know
what that is is that the only footage
that looks like three people dude wait
that's the footage that's bad I want to
see where this guy's going there's no
other footage no it looks like three
people watching that's the main slice of
footage that I've seen that guy walks
weird right so is that really Al hard to
tell what it so that's the thing right
so a lot of people are are immediately a
lot of the ufologists and stuff they
start talking about it like okay is this
an alien and [__] like that and then
there's another video let me show you
guys [__] ads yeah hey let's see the
ads yeah I want to see this alien at dve
and Busters you know there's an alien at
dve and Busters that's what I want to
see I thought he was like in the mall
like by Bed Bath and Beyond and [__]
waiting at dinong yeah yeah check out
the menu they're like if your whole
part's not here you can't sit down like
I don't know aliens like sh
can I get a Shalom b and a neom man
please oh the man names H that doesn't
look like an alien that looks like three
guys walking together that's actually
what Forbes is saying shut the [__] up
Anthony let's like go through it
together all right go
Fox that's what people were saying they
saw right the foggy one okay why is the
footage so shitty yeah where's the body
cam footage yeah why is that one all H
so this is the clear one M's kind of
nice huh yeah but damn that's a lot of
cop cars that's a [__] kind of nice huh
yeah you ever been to Miami no it's like
Latin Hawaii dude my sister lives there
I need to go Miami is pretty nice I want
to go I like Hawaii and I like Latin I'm
just worried if I go over there I'm
going to come back with a BBL you know
what I mean come on I'm surprised the
alien didn't have big old butt it did
actually it it said it had a huge junk
in the TRU it almost feels like in Miami
you have to have a butt or else you just
can't qualify you ain't [__] and you
have to live in
Orlando yeah Fort Lauderdale or
something I like aliens all aliens does
this get you excited this alien story it
does get me excited you hear about the
new Bob Lazar movie there's a movie
coming out yeah there's like a
documentary or something and it's about
uh the the the [__] spaceship that's
just floating around or something I saw
I saw a poster for it it's coming out
it's a movie about a spaceship that's
just floating around oh yeah B Lazar
talking about it oh yeah he's oh yeah
yeah that's coming out did you hear
about it Steve the new Bob Lazar movie
yes it's uh it's it looks like the what
the [__] oh I see it now oh is it cuz of
I see it now I see it now what the [__]
is that thing oh no it's three friends
walking together three cops walking
together side by side godam all it was
all it was it foggy imagery of three
cops walking together side by side this
is as clear as [__] that's why when
you film stuff guys go like this okay
and then wipe it cuz when you got a
smudge it makes everything look like
aliens well no but it wasn't even a
smudge cuz the that's the OG footage why
is GoPro footage better than this people
were fogging up the image to make it
look like a [__] alien to support the
thesis yes that alien was walking pretty
sexy it looked like three guys walking
together just from the I agree with you
especially like cuz I immediately saw it
cuz all these UFO things were popping up
it looked like they were walking like
this from far away like they're just
switching it doesn't look like I mean I
don't know what an alien looks like
right walk like yeah I know that's
holding their heels they're doing that
thing when friends walk with their legs
like
this their arms are locked together all
they're doing is like hey you ever did
this you ever did
this hey let's all lock arms and SE
some there is that there is that uh
little well I actually like this stuff
but there's that new [__] uh footage
or whatever that came or photo that came
in from that one telescope the web
telescope or whatever that just went out
that shows that there's um a planet that
they found 7 million light years away
that has like city lights or electricity
or something like that yeah that's
that's their deduction again anything
that's like
cops cop so before they had like the
Hubble telescope that they put out in
like the 9s or something like that that
was able to like you know capture
footage that was um they got it outside
of the Earth's atmosphere because back
then all we had was like a telescopes
from Earth but because of the Earth's
atmosphere it was hard to break through
and visualize certain things so they
sent out the Hubble telescope in the
'90s that would uh basically uh go
around the earth and be able to capture
data that way now they sent out this the
web telescope or whatever that um
basically goes orbits the Sun so it's
like farther out and they've been able
to collect a bunch of data that's crazy
and apparently they found some sort of
Planet 7 million light whatever the
[__] number is um that that's [__]
Far Man evidence of of like some sort of
like electrical City Light type
situation but because it's so far is it
possible that like that planet doesn't
exist anymore yeah it's very possible or
it's probably just reflection or
something that's what always could have
been what if it was just a volcano a
space apparently that's that's fake too
that's what so you can't trust dancers
is it fake it's fake too yeah did you go
on Snopes we're supposed to go through
this together why did you look up the
article ahead of time F new you're so
petty dude this isn't CNN man why are
you lying to me I'm hard right now it's
quick do another one why are you lying
to me have you guys heard about the Bob
Lazar movie that's coming out and it's
about a a ship that's just floating
sound pretty interesting it sounds
pretty interesting actually no
apparently that was AI generated yeah
the the one that you're talking about
the city lights thing I can't believe
anything stries again man can't dude
honest you really can't from here on out
anytime I hear UFO I'm just going to be
the sad sad boy that goes that's
probably [__] yeah unless I see it my
own eyes yeah like so Steve was that the
real reason kids were fighting at the
mall cuz it look dude it was Overkill I
was talking to somebody about this and
like why would they shut down the
airport cuz they shut down the Miami
airport nearby why they shut down the
airport and have like all every cop in
town show I'm like
I lived in La every time there anything
[__] happened they call every [__]
cop in the city like you better believe
cops over we at like LA or El Segundo
cuz those are two different places no
David David so is the guy who doesn't
know where
La actually I lived here for 15 years
damn man I did see a trailer for a
sci-fi movie that's coming out soon
apparently that I thought was really
cool uh ISS International Space Station
anybody see that movie trailer no so
basically it's it talks about the the
the Russian and American collaboration
in the International Space Station yeah
and then they look down on the planet
they see all these nuclear warheads go
off so basically it says that Russia and
America got into war and then each of
them separately got a message from their
respective country that said like take
over the station at all costs and so now
they're just stuck and it's kind of tie
I'm like yo can we talk about a better
trailer so there's another one that came
out Spider-Man 4 no it's the Civil War
of America did you see that one what
what do you mean it's called the Civil
War of America this movie sounds better
no if there was a Civil War what is
going to happen and then they have like
the Texas Republic the Eastern Union oh
I know what you're talking about I saw
that one that's a real movie that's
coming out I saw the trailer when is it
coming out I don't know but it looks
like we're heading there that's it's
sick that we came together though to
make a space station with Russia but we
can't get along with them down here
that's pretty cool what state you going
to be a part of I don't know dude you
better figure out now there's a so
there's a guy I'm not going to tell you
what kind of guy he is that I met at the
gym this morning and he just found out
that he realized that uh I live in uh
Nevada but I come here quite a bit and
he goes oh you're a by Wester a by
Wester so what kind of guy was this I
don't know is he a tax guy he sounds
like a Yeah by Westerner yeah although I
got to throw by into
everything everyone's by so does that
mean you're a part of the lgbtq RS I
don't know what he was trying to say he
was trying to add you did you say RS
like toys RS no those are the two
letters that got added recently RS don't
they just call him the alphabet
Community now or is that derogatory I
think that Chappelle calls him that oh
oh damn dude the new the new Chelle
stand up was
sick cuz he bashes on trans people every
time I try to bail this guy out he sinks
[Music]
it
for